hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so today is a very big
day we have a special guest nine to five
trader that he that is here with us so
if you don't know this guy already guys
go on his channel on his youtube channel
in the description of this video follow
him uh this is the first guest we are
having and guys the reason why is
because i watch his video and this is
great content he's doing technical
analysis just like i do we have slightly
different methods but i'm very excited
to see what he has to say on amc against
gamestop and discuss a few plays so
thank you bro for being here and i give
you some time to introduce yourself
[Music]
awesome yeah thanks for having me man
yeah so guys uh my channel is nine to
five trader go ahead and check it out
kind of the philosophy behind my channel
is that i myself work a nine-to-five job
but i'm on the you know i'm on the
pathway of trying to become a full-time
trader so throughout my channel
so throughout my channel guys i want you
to be a part of that journey we're going
to be making videos in and out i host
you know pretty frequent live streams as
well and i'm very active with our
community so
if you guys are bigger into more
technical analysis my channel is
probably more of your flavor i don't do
a whole lot of dd in catalyst but i
think that's you know where me and you
can have a nice
you know blend there but if you guys are
more in the technical analysis or follow
more of that be sure to check out my
channel and i'll be sure to show you
guys some things so
that's all i have for for my channel
okay cool cool so uh once again so of
course i watched your your videos and i
can see the so you you're using tier
just like i do
and uh i would be very interested to
know a bit what do you think we're gonna
start with uh the stocks that you guys
want to see so let's start with amc and
gamestop
so maybe 925 can show us what he thinks
might happen in uh
i don't know this week or maybe next
month and what how what kind of targets
maybe you have
and then you guys already know mine so
then we're just gonna switch to other
stocks and we're going to discuss
everything the different methods that we
both use so i think it's going to be
very interesting to compare actually our
method i saw you uh bro we're using fibs
as well but i think you use it a bit
differently from what i do so let's just
check everything let's compare so once
again let's start with amc or gamestop
up to you i'll let you share your screen
and let's let's see what you what you
have there
yeah perfect man i definitely want to go
over amc
so let's see i do need so i'm disabled i
need screen sharing it's okay
let me get some screen sharing real
quick yeah you got it bro just give you
there we go cool
amc yeah so i already have it charted
here i'm kind of cheating a little bit
but
let me clear it up here
i'm really excited about amc personally
okay i'm looking to add to a position or
a load to or start positioning in to
this as we approach the next day here so
i'm gonna show you why i'm gonna show
you the things that i'm seeing i'm
pretty excited about it so i have amc
pulled up here on the four hour chart i
like to look at the bigger time frame it
helps validate kind of the things we're
seeing a little bit more just as that
that much more significant so i see that
trend line we've been holding here so
net overall i've been up trending the
last three months i'm excited about that
and then from here you know i think we
are sitting in a big bowl pennant on the
four-hour chart now there's been a lot
of sentiment with amc recently i know
their ceo you know he has came in out he
has came out recently and said he has
something big uh you know playing for us
soon he likes to spit out catalyst like
at the right time and it's typically
around a good technical point too so i'm
pretty excited here let's see what can
happen in the near future but yeah you
know as we zoom in here i think amc is
at a very cheap buy
i don't think it can get much lower than
this it's possible
uh but we're sitting very low on the rsi
we're at a 34.
i just really like the way things are
looking there's not as much downside i
would think being that we're at such a
low point
on this on the price right now so i like
amc i'm looking to buy it
in terms of fibs so i like to do two
different things with fibs i know things
are subjective
but we can try uh fib retracement so i
usually like to come from my my longer
term swing high and swing low to me
that's what those are and then you know
that's where we're currently sitting so
i have these areas for fib now depending
on when i'm looking to trade right i
like to keep it relative so i'd actually
like to place the fib that's more
relative to the price action and i've
seen that validate at least in my
experience
for me so right now again we're kind of
at the bottom of that fib yeah we can
come a little bit lower it wouldn't
surprise me the price does come as low
as like 34 dollars but wouldn't be it's
a problem if we break this trendline i
pretty much agree with this analysis i'm
using the same upper band and lower band
uh like triangle trend lines kind of
yeah um
but you're saying that if we break this
so the level is around 35.5
on my side
so what would
so you still think it's possible we just
break it fake out there a little bit and
come back right away right this is what
you're saying
yeah yeah absolutely i think like i
think there's still breathing room here
i just like the the premature signs we
started to see towards the tail end of
friday so i kind of want to highlight
that price action if we come in
so here's friday here and i liked how we
i like how we ended the day yeah we saw
the bounce exactly at the level yeah
yeah pretty much agree on that
so i need a little more confirmation uh
the one hour looks really good so what
kind of confirmation would you be
looking for on monday for example
what would you like to see uh to be like
more bullish and you know really i
believe in the in the scenario of
a strong bounce
yeah so
for me
for me it's going to be so i like it
when it happens on the higher time frame
so for me like a very strong confidence
strong confluence
um at this point as well would have to
be some kind of green candle that closes
on the four hour above this high right
here of this previous bread candle so
about 30 i see 37.95 i'm gonna call it
38. yeah today it is the level i pretty
much agree with that
so if we get to if we if we can get to
38 or get above 38 i'm pretty confident
you know that's pretty much a good sign
of a bouncer very strong bounce
especially if the candle is closed like
that it might have some drawdown right
after 38 just because that's a critical
level right we're gonna see resistance
there so maybe it comes back down to
like 37 for a little bit whatever
but i think again that's that's strong
confirmation especially there's a lot of
volume there to support that
so i like that
okay great great um
so like i said i pretty much agree with
this analysis i use elliot waves as well
as you guys know
and for me we are still like in a
corrective mode uh but we're close to
the lows so um
so i'm i'm quite positive here as well
what would be your target uh if we break
uh if we break the upper band you know
on the upside do you believe like emc
can reach like soon some crazy levels
you know some people talk are talking
about hundred thousand you know some
very high levels of squeeze uh do you
think this is possible and if uh if yes
when and if not where do you think we
might be heading uh if we break this
upside uh at the bend
okay yeah there's a lot so there's a lot
to that and i definitely think
so this is amc at the end of the day we
gotta understand
all the all the dark pool data we've
been seeing all the short interests we
gotta keep track of all that we can use
or text whatever it is but with that
underlying movement happening and all
the just all the intertwining movement
of the stock
i think this stock is susceptible to
just a lot of momentum like
the fact that there's a lot of volume in
this already and a lot of people trading
it
we're gonna see nice big moves just off
technical breakouts but i think that's
where the underlying dark pull movements
that happen all the shorting i think
that's also going to help you know
induce a possible squeeze or give a lot
of momentum so
being conservative right
i like to use the fib on the bigger time
frame because
again if the bull pennant we're
observing is on the bigger time frame i
want to keep the fib relative to that
if we break out of this bowl pennant
i like that i like that interim swing
high i like about 52.85 about that level
maybe even 53 nice whole clean number
um
i like that level if you break out of
this bowl pendant which could happen the
next few days or weeks
and then again
you know how the stock light likes to
act when it gets to the 50s and 60s so
again that's just assuming a technical
breakout that's conservative and then
again that's where we could see a lot of
squeezing possibly happening
last time we've been in this territory
with a lot of momentum i mean it got
pretty parabolic right
so it you know we've only been in the
50s like a few times
okay okay that's uh that's a very good
analysis
um thank you for sharing that i think
it's gonna be very interesting for uh my
viewers to see what you think and that
basically we converge uh we're using
slightly different methods but we
converge on our support levels on our
resistance levels uh i on my hand i have
a target of 135 that i get using fibs
you guys already saw that so i'm gonna
you know no need to show it here um i
would like uh you uh brother to share
your opinion now on gme uh see if we
agree as well on this one and what do
you see coming
um
so let me know what you see there
yeah we'll take a look at jimmy actually
this will be a fresh chart to me so
let's do that and yeah your fibs
you know i use fibs differently like i
i use fibs i use fib retracements and i
just base off of that but like yeah i
think the 100s and whatnot like i've
seen that uh utilizing extensions and
i've seen it up there
because you know that's what that's what
kept popping up to me when i was
watching it uh squeeze when it got into
the 70s i was like oh my gosh like this
is possible because when people were
saying like 150 and all this i'm like
how they getting that you know fibs were
kind of new at the time i was like okay
yep that's a fib level next so
um
kind of when you're in no man's
territory i found those those phases
would be very useful because you just
don't know where it's going exactly it
just gives like a approximative target
but that is often actually reached and
where we often see some selling pressure
arriving whenever it's a new high
so yeah i i like to use fit projections
as well they give quite good uh
reactions usually
so i like um
i like gme i think you know it's the
same thing as amc
um in terms of you know being part of
that community there the reddit
community the social media meme as
stocks squeeze potential manipulated
i like gme there's still a heavy
sentiment behind it and then even
fundamentally they're looking sounder as
a company ryan cohan taking the lead
i like that very bullish on that
uh
this setup looks great this looks like a
symmetrical triangle maybe i'm a
triangle guy i'm a trendline guy if you
guys haven't seen that or figured that
out yet like i use your lateral
resistance and support levels i see them
more mentally and i also use my
crosshairs here they typically align
with a lot of other things i see with a
trend line so i just stick with that
i still think that overall we're seeing
a nice bullish pattern here again i'm on
the daily chart if we go to the max
chart right that it just it looks great
there i mean
you know higher or lower highs and
higher lows so i like that
and then we dial in
going to the four hour
you know kind of the same thing here i
think you know as we get closer to that
trend line again trend lines are
generalized and again i drew this on a
different aggregation period so the
trend line's going to be a little off
the price action
but i think when we generally get in the
vicinity of a trend line we need to
start watching things close that's where
you want to come in and potentially try
to grab a div maybe start positioning in
that's kind of what i'm going to be
looking to do on gme if i'm looking to
play it obviously look for other
confluences right we want to wait for a
bounce we want to wait for confirmation
a curl whatever but i think we're in the
vicinity of that possible buying
opportunity so
uh technically gme looks great
fundamentally we talked a little bit
about that i like the company as a whole
and again you know this kind of falls
categorically in the whole theme of meme
as stocks things like that so they have
insane potential to run so i like the
way gme looks right now do you mean amc
are
approaching a buy for me first okay
cool cool uh so once again i pretty much
agree with this uh ta i have this kind
of same of uh triangle here as well on
gme uh i'm seeing like uh higher highs
higher lows uh you like on the long term
so this is bullish we are above the 200
day uh moving average so everything to
me looks great we just take a little bit
of time uh but i i really do believe
we're gonna see some nice press action
developing sooner so that's great uh i
have a few questions to ask you you know
to to know a bit more about yourself
what brought you actually in trading so
you're in independent trader right so
how long have you been doing that what
brought you there um
yeah
yeah so um
i don't know what brought me to trading
it's it's hard so you know obviously
everyone's in it for money and for the
most part but
uh as i as i pursued trying to learn it
i just started to enjoy it a lot more
and i'll elaborate on that but i
probably started about
um maybe two years ago um i got i got a
lot more serious like a year ago but
about
so i won't say about three years ago is
when i started to entertain it then
about two years ago is when i got a
little more serious than in the last
year i've been doing a lot more
executing so
i really spent time digesting the
markets learning the markets and that's
leading me into my next point here is
that trading i originally was just like
man you know i've always wanted to be in
the stock stock sounded crazy fast paced
cool wolf of wall street just like
people making tons of money really fast
i'm like this is crazy it's multi the
multiples are insane
and i just took time to understand it as
i did that i started to enjoy it um i i
liked how insane it is like there's
never a dull moment and
it's nice too because it kind of forces
you to stay engaged with just what the
hell is going on in the world like i
used to never be or have any real
knowledge in like politics the economy
all that good stuff business all
everything everything and now that i
follow the stock market man i know so
much stuff i don't even need to know but
it's it's going to be advantageous to me
right real estate market gas and oil
gold
cryptocurrencies um inflation
yeah you need to follow everything now
you need to so i just i just grew a
passion for it and i just and then i i
think i just i just it just naturally
resides with me you know i just
personally like
i always was looking for that thing that
uh kind of you know what's my natural
passion what i really like to do and
this stuff i mean i just get it i just
get it this stuff clicks with me i
understand the technicals i understand a
lot and it's just
i like it man it's crazy never a dull
moment it's so fast-paced
um and it's really just a game of
discipline that's a very very heavily
psychological
uh but yeah that's kind of i got into
trading i'm just going to stick with it
man yeah okay very very nice pitch man i
pretty much
feel uh feel the same it's a very nice
environment very exciting uh especially
this the past few few years there's been
so many opportunities i personally do
believe we're gonna stay in this kind of
environment for at least one or two more
years uh what i mean by this kind of
environment is a strong bull market so
this is one more reason i believe you
know stocks like amc and gamestop that
are you know two legends now are are
gonna go higher uh because there is so
much money and you know in trading i'm
an ex-trader we have a saying that is
money needs to find a home and there is
so much money everywhere in the world
and this money just needs to go
somewhere you know the guys that are
working asset managers bankers whoever
they need to you know they receive money
and they just need to invest they cannot
sit on it so even those guys they're
getting into the amc trade uh they're
buying pretty much everything they can
all right so i i and for this reason i
don't think we're gonna stop having this
flow of money coming into the economy
right now uh and for this reason i
believe we're going to see uh new
all-time highs for like the next year on
the and the s p 500 and everything that
is hot to me so crypto is hot meme
stocks are hot
the spy is hot everything is just gonna
go higher and
and yeah i'm gonna try to monitor if i
see any signal that this uh you know
this might shift but for now uh this is
looking pretty good to me so same same
as you i'm very excited to to be in this
environment and and to just analyze and
try to find the the best uh place so one
more question for you what is the
perfect setup for you
i know like we are traders we all have
our uh you know uh preferred uh signals
that we like to combine
uh so what is for you if i if i need if
if i ask you what is the perfect setup
where you would put your money in uh in
terms of ta um
[Music]
what would you say it's maybe not an
easy question i mean but i'm still
asking you to
and see what you have to say
yeah yeah for sure um
yeah so
yeah
for me
it's a couple things and i i swear no
kidding no buys uh amc is literally
like
it's top five on my list to buy tomorrow
seriously so
it's just it so i have i have a few
major confluences and that's pretty much
what you're asking right what are my
confluences what you know what are the
what are the things i'm checking the box
on to say i'm very confident in this
trade right
okay
so a few things uh for sure volume i am
a volume chaser now i am a momentum
breakout trader i'm aggressive i like
the one minute we go in however
i like to trade on the five or the one
five minute or the one hour too it just
depends okay like
it's just hard for me to you know not
take profits when i can
but i like to look for volume high high
volume the higher the better
i like to trade things
so for example when would you uh
when would you go in a train if you have
you're gonna check for example the
five-minute time frame and whenever you
see an increase of volume with a
short-term breakout for example uh
then you would jump in the trade during
the day or do you wait for for the close
of the day
what type of um of trading would you do
in this situation
so i pretty much hopefully this answers
it i look for setups that look like they
are a ticking time bomb like they look
like they're going to break out i like
to show before the party starts so i
find setups that look like that if it
could happen in the next day or two
and i'm like this is gonna happen based
on you know abcdef there's a good chance
this breaks out tomorrow i jump in i
wait for that breakout and then i target
a level based on fib in like interim you
know support and resistance levels and
then i just kind of watch it run along
the way and then i dial into the one
minute from a granular view and say hey
because it's hard to know when
it's hard to know when to get out they
say you can't time the peaks but you can
get pretty damn close so you just watch
those one minutes and then as soon as
you see a significant breaking structure
maybe that's against a strong trend line
whatever
that's when i get out so i show up
before the party starts wait for it to
erupt
and then as it's erupting that's where
you really got to kind of dial in you
know it's landing the plane it's that
last part of the flight so you got to
just really focus in
and that's pretty much how i do it and
then if but if it looks bullish
throughout the day
um i just keep looking i look for trend
lines i'm a trend trader too trend is
your friend
so
that's applicable to the one minute if
it looks really bullish for the entire
day just from the get go off market open
and it keeps pulling back but creating
higher lows on the pullback i'm just
going to keep playing that in and out
because that's telling me it's still
going to run the rest of the day
um
hopefully that answered it that was
pretty elaborate but now that's very i
mean like for me it was very clear
because you know i'm a ta guy so i i i
pretty much i sold many different uh
traders using different techniques so
for me you are anticipating breakouts
you like to buy
uh low but whenever you have some
bullish very short-term signals you know
you have different types of traders you
have traders that like to buy at the
lowest possible level and you have
traders that like to buy at high levels
and say even higher
so uh to me you are a bit between those
two stars because you like to buy uh
before the breakout but whenever you
start to have some bullish signals on
the short on the shorter
time frame
uh which is uh which is a very good uh
way of training
so very interesting
um
very interesting thanks for sharing that
um
maybe we can do now another uh things a
bit the other way around so maybe you
can ask me uh one or two stocks that you
would like me to see i'm not gonna lie i
checked your youtube so i know that you
are into prague and femi so i checked
those two already so you can ask me
those i have something to say or you can
ask me anything else it would be very
interesting for me to start from scratch
as well so i'll let you ask me what what
you what you prefer
okay i got two and one of them you're
familiar with one you might not be so
let's start with the familiar one let's
do uh fami let me know what you think of
family i'm pretty bullish on this and
this is an anticipation play
and
it's you know it's a micro cab low float
now to me the technicals are screaming
okay
there is
volume you show us quickly what you see
on femi uh yeah
and then i'm gonna show you what i see
and let's discuss that it's very very
interesting so uh do you want me to
start on my screen yeah yeah yeah start
first then i'm gonna show my screen so
i'll let you uh you i still see your
screen so
tell us so
family i'm excited um
so on the weekly
i'm just seeing somebody so much
confluence but on the weekly
i i think i think we're attempting i
think there's an inflation point i think
this trend line is valid okay trend
lines i get it they're subjective
generalized whatever
i like this weekly trend line a lot of
people are talking about it
i don't know why i've seen trend lines
like this validate as far as 20 years
back in time okay
so i think there's trend lines here how
close are we to it that's the next
question i think what's screaming with
all of this is that not only are we at a
significant inflection point of that
trend line but this company is trading
consistently in maintaining
at the highest volumes it has seen since
going public by far i mean this thing
has been a volume leader for six to
about six weeks straight it's been top
ten most traded stocks on the u.s market
and nobody's talking about it i don't
know what's going on how many share
what's the volume exchange exchanged
every day here for example if i take the
biggest one we have right what i see one
billion oh yeah that's a lot i am and
yeah half uh
around a billion uh us dollars exchanged
the the the highest days so yeah that's
definitely a lot for for this kind of
stock
yeah that's just odd
so to me yeah it's spec i'm speculating
right but
that's part of the game and i'm
speculating on this style because it's
just too weird and diving a little bit
deeper there is a lot a short float in
here it's about 35 percent
possibly you're in a falling wedge more
interim i don't know i've seen plays
like this i understand the personality
of this stock to an extent
and there's there's going to be a lot of
faking out there's going to be a lot of
stop-loss hunting this is extremely
volatile and very manipulated if you
watch it on the one-minute candle you
will see it
fami i'm just really bullish on uh the
volume's been picking back up to the
last three trading days
something's going on
the weather goes down it goes down but
you know we're so cheap already so i
really like family i'm bullish on it and
uh yeah i'm just really curious what you
think okay okay but maybe i can share my
screen uh and i'm gonna show you what i
see there
all right so here we go
semi it should be good
do you see my screen
yeah
yeah great
all right so um i'm using a log scale so
this is a bit different from what you
are doing so i'm going to have slightly
different trend lines so i can start on
weekly time frame just like you did
and uh so if i start from you know 2018
i have a trend line that i would draw
uh here
so sorry i'm just wondering if
okay i'm going to put that here it's
perfect okay so i have this trend line
that i use connecting the two highs that
i have here then i have one more
reaction here and then i had a breakout
in
let's say jan 21 so for me here this is
the first breakout that could have been
used as a signal to get in we have the
breakout what i like to do in this those
stocks that are just you know dropping
i like to identify uh
a breakout that i usually get using a
trend line
and i usually don't buy the breakout
unless we have you know a big
consolidation before so here we had a
bit of conservation so maybe i could
have bought this breakout but i would
usually buy the retest so here it would
have worked then we had this huge run up
and then we it does it just got dumped
quite
badly here so to me whenever we broke
this trend line at this level uh this is
looking bad you know because when we
have this kind of trend lines that are
just uh going lower they are broken
re-tested but not holding and we are
below the moving averages this looks bad
so from there we correct it quite
heavily and right now what i'm seeing
is um
so we are very low so i agree this stock
is cheap but the question we are having
is uh can it go lower and when would we
have for me all the positive signals to
get in
so the first good uh so let me go back
on a daily time frame and now i'm gonna
try to see
if so we are bearish i mean on the on
the medium term we're just going lower
we're making lower lows uh lower highs
so we're in a bearish trend but we
already have a bullish divergence that
we can get using macd which is a
momentum indicator or rsi which is
another momentum indicator so here we
can see that the market is making lower
lows but during the same time
the momentum which is macd or rsi both
went higher so this is for me the first
bullish signal that we have that means
that the bears are out of steam uh that
they are tired that they don't have that
much uh
more money to put in the stock to put
push it lower so this is positive we
then had this very strong bounce here
and we to me created this upper band
wedge
this wedge upper band uh where we got
rejected first
uh we came back here so i have support
at the recent low so we are right around
it around like 0.3 i have you know a
support level at around here um
i could buy right now if we go lower i
would definitely uh try to get in
you know more around this level you know
it would be a new low depending on how
fast we go there what is the momentum if
we arrive very strongly i would be
careful but if we arrived there we
stayed there a bit then i would be
probably a buyer around this levels i
would use some short-term uh signals to
get in
and my real
signal because i'm more a swing trader
than a day trader just because you know
if you want a day tread you
you need to be extremely focused to
follow everything in hong kong you know
i'm just not in the right time zone to
do that
um so it's mostly for this reason
otherwise i would enjoy doing more day
trading and here my signal would be if
we so i'm not saying we're going to go
lower all right this is not my preferred
scenario i don't really know what's
going to happen you know in the coming
days but what i know is that if we
arrive here and we have this breakout
retest you know this would create for me
a very nice signal so i'm gonna give you
the level all right i'm gonna put that
in green
and to me this would be a good signal
because we would have we would be close
to this um trend line all right so this
is still acting as resistance so maybe
it would be even better if we trade
above that but if we ignore this trend
line which is a long term trend line we
would here have a wedge
breakout on the upside with a bullish
divergence those two signals combined
usually give very
good results i mean we usually see a
strong move up happening afterwards once
again usually uh when we come from the
highs and we are in a downtrend uh the
reversal usually takes some time so here
depending if we have a consolidation
just below the upper band of the wedge
or not uh i would buy the breakout or i
would wait for the retest but definitely
i think we have something nice to do
here
um
then on those kind of stocks which are
once again we're trading much higher so
how how high this was trading at 10 okay
yeah yeah that we're turning much higher
um
i would probably try to exceed you know
at least if i'm in this trade and it
goes in my in the right direction i
would probably try to take some profits
around the one level
115 because i see here we have you know
this trend line that i get once again
using the log scale
so yeah this is the trade i would do uh
i would either buy on the on the
downside uh close to the lower band of
the wedge pattern or on the upside after
breakout and maybe re-test and i would
try to take profits around one so we
have a very nice move to come if this
happens we're talking here about around
250
so this is of course a beautiful uh
setup that i would be right now
monitoring it was not in my watch list
i'm gonna add it
so yeah that's what i see on femi so
let's see what's hap what's happening
there but it's definitely a stock uh to
follow
oh yeah okay
yeah man i like it i like the uh yeah i
totally agree i think you know i
definitely think um we can fall further
down that wedge i think it's a
possibility in that buy region around i
think you had it around like the teens
the high teens i can see it you know
coming down to that wedge i think that's
possible um
yeah you know i just i was just so
bullish on it because uh i really think
it's accumulating now it's insane you
know the volume is just so insane we had
it we had we had dilution right we had a
share offering
it got beaten down like a pulp
and then we had accumulation it traded
sideways on high volume for weeks and
then it flagged up to 53 cents
and then it cooled down from that
i don't know what's next but it's insane
there's a ton of volume on it i mean
it's unbelievably unspoken of it's
trading it's averaging 100 million a day
and it's a chinese mushroom company it
made something going on i'm no news yeah
there's something going on yeah i'm
pretty excited
all right cool cool maybe you have one
more uh oh yeah that i can talk about
and assassin
s-e-s-n i'm very bullish on this
[Music]
i'm into this one i'm into this one not
sensionic but that looks really good
actually let me
that looks awesome man said tiana
holdings yeah actually i know a lot
about that company no assassin
it's not the right one oh excuse me i
always mix them up it's all good
all right so this is so as you can see i
already have two trim lines here so it
means i have already checked that
so i'm gonna do the usual stuff i'm
gonna first start on the weekly time
frame try to see a bit the trend so here
we are ranging right this stock started
to trade in 2015 even to a 14
uh it's making low highs all right
uh bam bam okay i can make a trend line
here uh i'm gonna remove those two
because i don't remember why i put them
and i'm gonna try just to you know
structure a bit what is happening here
so once again we are rengi
uh since 2015
uh so for this kind of stocks we need to
find some resistances above which we
would start to be bullish
uh
so it's not that obvious here so the
support line is
more clear we have we can make a lower
band here
the upper man is not perfect here
because as you can see i have you know
we went above then came back
so here i would have been maybe a buyer
i would have tried to set up a trade
here i would have get stopped
right away
right now i'm not sure what i would do
here let me try to see if we have any
signals coming from the momentum so the
rsi is not oversold and we are starting
to go higher we have a very nice volume
all right that's a good information uh
so let me go back on a daily time frame
for now i struggled to find some strong
resistances above which i would turn
bullish i'm still trying to zoom in to
see what i can get
it's interesting to see first thing i
see
is that we had the strongest volume ever
that traded on which day was that
it was on the 20th of october so it was
on thursday wednesday or thursday it was
on a move up
uh so let's see what let's zoom in here
a little bit
i like what i what i see here we traded
above the moving averages all right we
were basically just dropping
lower
i would say you know i try to make a
trend line here okay i get it now i
start to see clear more clearly what's
happening there
um
okay so i have here a small trend line
that
we broke here
and we went above the 20-day moving
average so this started to be bullish we
then consolidated and moved higher so we
are definitely in the bullish
development
since this breakout let me put it in
green
okay it's pretty much where we had this
strong volume kicking in
so we are going in the right direction
but
i have to say
that for now it's not really enough for
me
okay here i have a trend line you know
we have to me you know a strong
resistance that would come around the
200-day moving average
so here i could use fibs as well just
i'm gonna measure the last move down and
i'm gonna see where we are in terms of
retracement so we are still very close
to the lows
so to turn bullish here i would need to
see a bit more bullish price action
i would like to see the price uh taking
back the 38.2 retracement level of the
last move down which is where we have
the 200-day moving average so around 250
to 70
all right so if i see the price action
coming there then i would try probably
maybe to jump in on the pullback or
something like this
um
it would be a bit early for me to buy
here because we have this strong bearish
day that to me created a lot of damage
i'm not sure the damage is fixed yet we
have a lot of uh bears that
might jump at it again around you know
basically those levels the guys that you
know missed the exit here
you know it's once again the breakout
level we have uh you know a few
indicators coming to the same uh levels
so here i start to see better
uh this is the breakout level of the
last move up all right so let me put
this one in green so this one is useless
i'm gonna get rid of that
i check and i'm gonna keep this one for
now
so what i see here is that here we have
this breakout on the downside let me put
it in orange
and this is to me the strong resistance
that we need to break
to really turn bullish so on the very
short term we have bullish signals
so my scenario here
would be
so it's a long shot but it would be that
we keep going higher and then he would
probably be rejected first and what
would happen from here
is you know the big question uh
either we're just gonna go lower and
then it won't be looking good or we just
go break this level finally and make new
highs so yeah why not uh making i mean
it's too late to buy i would be a buyer
maybe lower try to take profits around 2
30
buying at one selling at 2 30 all right
if you're in the street i think it's a
nice position to keep
um
and yeah once again i would take profit
around 240 250
i see a lot of resistance around this
level and then i could come back again
in the trade if we get rejected either i
buy lower uh you know so it's always uh
good to sell high and buy lower or i
would maybe buy higher after breakout
and retest around this level
so i would have a plan for both um
scenarios
um
so let's see i'm positive on the short
term but i don't know what's gonna
happen you know uh on the medium term we
have this 250 to 17 270 resistance that
is quite strong to me uh so let's see
but very interesting setup i'm gonna
keep an eye on this one as well
yeah yeah yeah i like it i like it yeah
so long term yeah for sure it's not you
know it's bearish right now it's in a
downtrend
uh it's trading somewhat sideways net
so long term not too bullish on it long
term uh for me this is more just going
to be an intraday scalp play
probably no more than a two day hold if
that
250 is actually what i had so that's
very good i'm actually looking for a gap
fill play here what i think again i
think this is a stock that got beaten
down uh and then we have we saw price
accumulating underneath which explains
the influx of volume stocks started to
curl out out of that accumulation phase
and about where that inflection point is
where they break out of that that range
they're trading in um puts us at a gap
fill uh leading up towards that 250
range so it's just a gap bill scout for
me that was really good though i do
appreciate that yeah long term
absolutely not i you know just just
being honest uh no it doesn't look good
long-term that's also a very good
observation there so i like it okay it's
funny because once again we use
different methods but uh i kind of feel
that we we agree upon many levels uh but
using different methods you know so this
is the beauty of ta is that you know
whenever you do some good analysis so
let's see if this is good or not maybe
we both wrong you know that's that's
possible as well but if we are right it
would be beautiful to see that using
different methods we come back to the
same
scenarios that eventually do happen i
mean not all the time but sometimes
so um so yeah it's very very interesting
um
i don't know do you have one more or we
can stop here we i mean i want to do
that again with you any uh yeah guys it
was really cool
um so if you have one more maybe we can
do one more or we can keep it for later
just let me know yeah i what's that
spreadsheet
take your genetic short synthetic short
yeah can you measure short data with
family do you have that yeah i did i
actually did that and i don't see i
don't see something huge
anything interesting uh i don't have
actually options on this one so i don't
know if i have an issue here let me uh
share my screen
um
[Music]
okay so this is the spreadsheet so i put
femi when when we were talking i checked
that immediately because this is
something i like to keep an eye on so
when i check fami i see that the market
cap is very small so this is a good
reason for you know having uh
you know some strong moves up because on
those small market caps whenever you
have a big player he can you know just
move the market by himself uh i don't
see options uh here so let me check
i don't know let me check it out there's
no options chain
you don't have options okay so this is
why i i don't see any synthetic short
this is what i like to monitor because
this is eating gamma so this is giving
some a strong bullish momentum um so i
don't see it here and i see uh on the
regular shots so maybe i'm a bit late
i'm gonna do on the 30th of september
and i see two percent so it's not big uh
let's check s-e-s-n
what i see here
we have some uh okay so here we have
it's a different story we have some
uh okay
so we have uh five percent of total
shots so it's not huge compared uh to
the market cap
let me check where those options are
coming from
so we can see so uh scsn is right now
trading at one and we can see that you
know this is uh interesting we have some
options uh on the one strike so this is
expected because it's around the money
but we also have on the two strike which
is the 100 strike so if we go around to
what would probably happen so it's not
very big let's be honest uh because we
go only from one percent of the total
slot share right now in synthetic short
to three percent which means that on a
move up um option market makers need to
buy two percent of the total share float
but as uh this stock is not trading that
much uh it can make the the difference
and we have this gamma around the two
strike so if we come close to two option
market makers would be buyers so this is
uh to me kind of confirming what we see
here because we both said that 250 to 70
is the level
so
it's funny to see that we have indeed uh
some you know some big positions of
options on this to strike which once
again if it's crossed would generate
some strong buying orders by option
market makers so this is not the biggest
one i've seen but we still have some
gamma here is there any other one you
want to check so
i can show you what i see
yeah um
do you want to chart one more you're
just going to enter something in the
into here because you can i'm curious to
see like amc maybe or bbig i know those
are heavily
uh
conversated stocks in terms of being
shorted okay so let's so amc because me
personally like i i
you know i don't know a lot about
shorting or understand i understand what
it is and stuff but i don't i don't know
like what's advantageous to know what
that what does it mean if it's getting
shorter a lot doesn't mean you could
squeeze like what all yes exactly
that's what it means all right so
uh bam
let me get it from amc first
so basically what i'm doing here i'm
retrieving all the
um
open interest on the option market
and i convert so it means that you have
uh you know some
open positions on call options for
example and i i do the assumption uh
that all the school options are hold by
retail investors and that the short side
is uh
is um that professionals are showing
this so option market makers and hedge
funds
and
this gives me information about what
short position they do bear against uh
the the retail investors that hold those
call options and here on amc i see that
this is what i call synthetic short and
i see that we have six percent of
synthetic short compared to the total
float share
so i then add this number to the regular
short interest that i get on the finra
reports which is 18
so we have 25 percent of
total short interest at this spot so
this is the first information it means
that whenever amc starts to move uh
strongly higher they're going to be a
lot of
shorts that are going to be in trouble
and that might
just buy the stock because they are
scared of a squeeze
and the other information that is very
interesting to get on
is the maximum synthetic shot that is
here 17
so this is the synthetic position that
would be on the market if amc goes to
very high levels so when whenever you do
the difference between the synthetic
short and the maximum synthetic short
which is here 11
it means that this is the the
the position that shorts need to buy on
the upside so this is the gamma this is
the bullish momentum and i like to
compare all of this to the daily volume
and this is the dtc day to cover which
is here 2.5 so this means that if all
short
players need to cover the short position
in the same day they would be trading
2.5 the daily volume so of course this
would uh become a squeeze and this
indicator is good to follow whenever
we're close to 5
or even 10 then usually we are squeezing
it's not that we might squeeze is that
usually we are in the process of
squeezing so this is interesting to to
follow um and this is pretty much the
information i get so once again on amc i
see that we have uh 25
of total short interest uh which is
which is a lot i mean you know
and on gme we have pretty much the same
up
yeah we have 18 i see here so we have a
little bit less but those two stocks
they are big market caps all right we're
talking about 10 20 billion usd
uh so
it shows how many people are basically
taking a short position here and this is
um this is i mean good news uh if we
start to have some higher highs some
upside breakouts because those guys i'm
pretty sure they have stop losses just
above you know those guys the notes here
they are professionals they know where
are the resistance levels uh usually and
they use a stop loss just above so if we
have this bullish signals on the upside
those guys many of them they would be
buying amc and gamestop so this is
another thing that i like to watch to um
to finish like the to build my view
using technical analysis
okay yeah yeah no i definitely uh
definitely want to learn more for sure
about shorting because
uh it just seems advantageous to know i
mean if you culminate that with a
technical breakout too
i mean my goodness some of these short
squeezes are ridiculous
ridiculous life-changing numbers i mean
it's insane and then you have gamma
squeezes too which seem a lot more
frequent i think i think gamma squeezing
happens more often but the gamma squeeze
actually can happen whenever you have
this um this big upside strikes so let
me show you for example on amc again we
have the 145 strike
that is uh generating a lot a lot of
gamma because uh
okay so it's here
as we can see on this chart
that is here
okay so uh i know there is a lot of
information here but what is interesting
is to see here the uh 145 strikes so
here you have the strikes and here you
have the number of shares in millions so
we have 17 million equivalent shares on
the 145 strike and this is what is
creating the gamma because those options
right now they don't have a big position
i mean the
the the equivalent position in terms of
share is not that big because it's very
far but if we get close to it or even if
we go beyond
that level the position uh would be much
bigger
which is good for uh buyers but for
sellers it means that the short position
is just growing
exponentially on the upside
so
they have to buy if amc starts to go
higher and this is the gamma it means
that whenever things go higher there's
going to be some um market makers that
are going to be
buying the stock to just hedge the
position and come back to a flat
position not even be long
so this is what i'm checking
145 strikes there's a lot of what is
that is that open interest there yeah
man it's the biggest open interest
usually you have the biggest open
interest around the 35 strike around the
money so here 35 and we can see here we
have
uh 5 million shares around which is the
biggest one uh you know close to the
money we then have some 50 with like 4
million you know but it's everything
below five six million and suddenly we
see this insane amount of options on the
145 strike which is basically a four
perce for 400 strike uh and this is
totally insane we have exactly the same
on gme let me show you again and we
don't see that on any other place i mean
when i check uh so prague for example
this one play i was following fisel as
well we don't have this crazy amount of
uh options on the upside if i check gme
bro look at that
so give me a sec
but it's the same as we do
up i just need to update my charts
yeah they expire
up one sec
all right and bro look at that same
thing
so dm is right now trading at so let me
put it jeez
a thousand hey man it's like uh so
around the 300 strike which is let's say
the money even if it's a bit higher this
is the biggest amount of option which is
1.3 million uh equivalent shares uh of
options and if you go to the 950 strike
you know the biggest strike that people
can find uh the amount of options here
is uh three million
all right so it's totally insane and
this is one and it's interesting to see
where it's coming from because i can you
know just get the information of which
maturity so i'm going to the 950 strike
and i check so i have my three million
shares and i can check where it's coming
from
and it's mostly coming from here
all right so this is
jan 22.
so this is giving me two information the
first information is that we're going to
have this kind of
explosivity on the upside until jan 22
because this is when we have this huge
expiry and another information that i
get is that i'm checking whenever we get
close then 22 i'm checking if this is
getting rolled if people you know if we
don't finish at crazy level
levels by gen 22 i'm checking if
investors are rolling those options to
gen 23 or march 22 whatever because if
they do this means that uh this is still
bullish that you know they still believe
in it and if i see that you know we
don't have that many options
anymore uh it would give me an
information that's all right people
start to get tired of it they're not
putting their money in this place
anymore uh so this would be a first
signal to me that we need to be careful
that maybe the squeeze uh is not uh is
not gonna happen i mean not right now um
but this is for now totally not
happening we have this immense uh amount
of options uh on the upside and on long
term i mean
gen 22 is not november is not october i
mean people put that on the longer term
and this has been the case for the past
month um
so this is once again giving information
that we have some believers that you
know just
push the price higher by buying those
very upside calls that would create a
lot of troubles for market makers and
for hedge funds if we start to move
higher so once again we need a catalyzer
we need something to to start the move
uh i think that game stop is around 250
above that it's a squeeze and amc is
around uh
50 i think
is around let me tell you yeah 50 55 all
right above that
even lower sorry it's even low it's even
45.
how did you get like 55 how did you get
those uh
so you think those are general like
squeeze locations like squeeze potential
locations uh yes i think that's so let
me share my screen here
okay
so i think that's basically we need to
have some bullish momentum to start so
we need to have a breakout that uh you
know just brings in bulls uh in this
market and if we have this breakout
um then we would have the first move up
and then the gamma would would probably
do the rest so here okay i got you you
see what i mean what i would like to see
is a breakout here
that would not uh kick in uh for the
gamma yet so here option market makers
they would be fine there would be a we
have time 145 is still far away we don't
need to buy shares but here i'm pretty
sure some bulls would get in and if we
go higher and break make a new high
above 53
roughly this would be a signal for more
bulls to get in and we would have i
think this bullish momentum that we are
waiting for that would trigger the stop
losses from those short
players
so
this is my view we need the first move
to drive some balls and then the shorts
would just do the rest by uh stopping
the positions
okay i totally agree with that yeah
that's one thing i've really noticed
with amc
um because you know i was listening to
that earlier where
i think a technical breakout is
significant because
you know that's gonna leach in a bunch
of volume it's just gonna it's just
gonna snowball with all this momentum
exactly
okay
damn yeah wow i didn't know uh there was
that much open interest at those strike
prices that's a nuts that's nice no that
existed and and i'm checking every stock
that you know people talk about uh that
people ask me to check
and i've never seen something like this
for any other stocks so you have amc
gamestop that are for me the two
legends that you know have all these
options on the very high strikes and
then you have the
other plays that you know are just pump
and dump you know you don't have this
strong uh buyers that just gonna hold
for a very long time so this is to me
the difference between you know the the
small place for example i like fisel i
like prague right now but i i don't
believe they will hold high they would
just pump and dump and then the money
would probably go to amc and gamestop
you know the long term place the real
place where we might we might see i do
believe some very high levels um
so let's see let's find out what's going
to happen
um
up let me stop the the share
all right
so thank you very much uh for uh for
being here uh it was very interesting uh
i really hope we can uh we can do that
uh we can do that again um i really
enjoyed talking with you and seeing like
the different techniques that you like
to use to compare it with mine uh so
thank you very much bro for being here
and uh i'll let you say the last word if
you if you want to say something
no no yeah it was fun man i i look
forward to more this is great and it you
know it's always good when you can uh
you know collaborate and link you know
on the same frequencies as someone else
who understands technical analysis and i
think we can bounce some great ideas off
each other so i appreciate you having me
man
okay cool thank you very much guys for
watching and stay close to shaw see ya